everybody sean mccann is here with the
GS news update now it's not often that
we cover the same news as TMZ but well
here we go Lindsay Lohan is suing
rockstar games for using her likeness
without her permission suit claims that
GTA 5's character Lacey Jonas is an
unequivocal reference to Lohan it also
goes on to say that Lohan's entire image
including her voice and clothing styles
were used without permission in GTA 5
the game includes a mission that has
players taking home a girl as she
attempts to evade the paparazzi there's
even a mission at a hotel that resembles
Chateau Marmont in West Hollywood where
Lohan formerly lived for a period of
time however the character could be
based on a good many Hollywood actresses
and probably more of a general
stereotype parody than based on any one
specific individual it's unclear what
Lindsay Lohan is hoping to gain from the
lawsuit but a report from yes TMZ says
she's demanding quote serious money a
parody of a character would be
classified as fair use so this case
appears to be more of a publicity stunt
than an earnest attempt at a cash grab
for more gaming news make sure to come
back to gamespot com for more lindsay
lohan news I really can't help you there